ich habe mich heute sehr gewundert über
den großen Klimagipfel in Glasgow da
treffen sich ja die Mächtigen dieser
Welt die Staats- und Regierungschefs die
großen CEOs die beispielsweise Amazon
Gründer Jeff Bezos und wollen darüber
sprechen wie man das Klima retten kann
und beim Klima retten gehen sie auch
darum worauf wir normale Menschen
verzichten sollen weniger Autofahren
weniger in den Urlaub fliegen nun wurde
aber die große Klimakonferenz zu einer
absoluten Parade für Privatjets die
Daily Mail die britische Zeitung Daily
Mail hat sich heute angeschaut wer alles
im Glasgow gelandet ist es wurden über
50 Privatjets gezählt insgesamt werden
über 400 Privatjets erwartet und da
frage ich mich diese Leute diese
Privatjet Parade soll uns raten wie wir
unser Leben verändern sollen um das
Klima zu retten also wirklich das ist
der absolute Gipfel der Doppelmoral und
darum geht eigentlich nur ein Zeichen
aus alles was die Politik dort berät das
kann ein normaler Mensch einfach nicht
ernst nehmen
ich glaube wir haben schon mit mit sag
ich mal dem Gipfel davor und Rom gesehen
dass wir auch da wieder nicht zu
Entscheidungen dass wir einfach eine
riesendiskrepanz zwischen verursachenden
und dann wieder ausbügelern haben in Rom
sind wir zu keiner Entscheidung gekommen
was wir denn jetzt tatsächlich neu
erreichen wollen in Schottland haben wir
jetzt genau die gleiche Thematik dass
ich da die westlichen Staaten daran
aufreiben dass sie nicht mehr ausgeben
wollen um dem Klimawandel
entgegenzuwirken und die die Staaten die
auch viel von dem CO2 verursachen oder
der CO2-Bilanz viel dazu beitragen sagen
wiederum wir brauchen Hilfe wir brauchen
eine Lösung und wir müssen als Kollektiv
eine einen Umstellung da finden ich
glaube die die Spitze des Eisbergs sind
wirklich tatsächlich nur diese
Privatjets aber das Problem ist einfach
eine eine ganz ganz ich glaube wir
können daran erkennen dass die
allermeisten Staats- und Regierungschefs
das Problem gar nicht erkannt haben und
nicht angenommen haben sondern sie
versuchen durchzukommen die denken an
wahl- und der Wahl und an
wirtschaftliches Wachstum und andere
Fragen die sehr viel näher liegen aber
an die Zukunft der Menschheit und das
Globus glauben die nicht wir haben so
schon gesehen wie Boris Johnson diese
Konferenz eröffnet hat mit dem Verweis
auf James Bond man brauche einen James
Bond da hat er sich bezogen auf einen
Film wo dem sozusagen eine Atombombe ans
Bein gebunden waren der musste die jetzt
entschärfen das ist wirklich eine
parallele die zeigt die ganze
unernsthaftigkeit nicht nur dieses
Mannes sondern der gesamten
Veranstaltung wenn Indien bekannt gibt
im Jahre 2017
klimaneutral zu sein kann ich nur sagen
hoffentlich gibt es Indien dann noch
wenn die klimaneutralen zahlen wollen
und das ist doch wir haben es doch
selbst bei Angela Merkel gesehen in den
letzten Jahren die immer behauptet hat
sie seine Klimakanzlerin was hat sie in
Wahrheit fürs Klima getan man könnte
fast sagen jedenfalls man könnte auch
mit Blick auf das Bild oder die Bilder
die Du gerade gesagt hast genannt hast
Philipp hau dare you Thema Gipfel
richtig und der größte doppelmoralist
das ist ja Boris Johnson selbst der
Gastgeber der ja mit seinem Land 2025
sogar klimaneutral werden will der sagt
es ist 1 Minute vor Mitternacht der aber
jetzt wieder gesagt hat er fährt die
Kohlekraftwerke hoch warum weil die
Gaspreise zu hoch sind weil er ein
Problem der Energiesicherheit in seinem
eigenen Land hat es gibt eine große
Debatte in Großbritannien gerade über
die Frage müssen wir eigentlich neue
Erdölfelder finden in der Nordsee um das
Land zukunftssicher zu halten um die
Wirtschaft am Laufen zu halten also hau
der juboris Johnson wir sehen zwar am
eigenen Land ehrlich gesagt ihr habt das
ja mal gemacht in der Bild-Zeitung ihr
seid mal in die in die flutgebiete
Gefahren nach Wochen und habe geguckt
was ist da eigentlich los und das viel
zu wenig los das Thema ist schon wieder
ausgebucht aus dem öffentlichen
Bewusstsein die Menschen die dort immer
noch drum kämpfen dass sie irgendeinen
Haus haben indem sie wenigstens wohnen
können auch wenn es nicht beheizt ist
dass sie Strom und Wasser haben die
fühlen sich doch zu Recht zu lassen wie
üblich wird das zugesagte Geld zu spät
ausgezahlt in zu kleinen Beträgen
ausgezahlt und unsere Diskussionen
drehen sich schon wieder am völlig
andere Fragen um diese Frage jedenfalls
nicht das ist ein ausgegrenztes Gebiet
als wäre es eine Exklave Deutschlands da
kämpfen die Menschen ums tägliche Leben
und niemand nimmt zum Teil diesen
flutgipfel ist ja auch einfach nicht so
sexy wie so ein Klima gibt ich meine wer
fliegt der 400 Privatjets die danach NRW
und Rheinland-Pfalz fliegen das würde
man sich ja wünschen
diese Doppelmoral du kannst ja wirklich
nur überzeugen wenn du selber mit einem
guten Beispiel voran gehst und wenn du
daher in Privatflieger dahin gehst dann
ist die ganze Debatte schon dahin weil
dann keiner mehr das glaubt was die
Leute machen aber der Gipfel zeigt ja
eins wir sind zu spät dran
wir sind global zu schlecht aufgestellt
und dann versuchen wir in Deutschland
als kleines Land überproportional zu
sagen unseren Beitrag zu leisten und
dann das führt dann bei uns zu immensen
Debatten und zu Verwerfungen auch zu
Spaltungen in der Gesellschaft und dann
baten wir ein bisschen das aus was
global verpasst wird ich habe war heute
auch erschrocken wo ich die Nachricht
gehört aber China 2017 gerade sagen
sogar
Greenpeace Leute gut besser als gar
keine Entscheidung aber 2017 ist
natürlich so weit weg da sitzen wir alle
nicht mehr hier und dann wollen die
immer noch nicht
vielleicht doch hier sitzen aber Frau
Tönnies das Thema Klima Bau sie sind
Chefin einer Firma die ja
it für den Bauherr stellt bzw
Überwachung eigentlich von Anlagen um
Bauvorhaben in im Zeitrahmen auch dann
durchführen zu können damit wenn was
kaputt geht sie da rechtzeitig reingehen
können um Verzögerung vorzubeugen
inwieweit ist dieses Thema was dort
diskutiert wird auf der Klimakonferenz
eigentlich für sie von Relevanz von
massiver Relevanz also im Bau mit der
gesamten Landwirtschaft oder
Bewirtschaftung von Gebäuden tragen wir
knapp 40 Prozent der gesamten tragen wir
zur Gesamtbilanz massiv bei und ich
glaube auch dass man einfach mal so eine
Wertschöpfungskette sich anschaut von
der materialproduktion bis zur
tatsächlichen Errichtung eines Hauses
und dann auch wiederum das was jetzt auf
uns zukommt mit entweder grüner grüner
Energie oder auch noch eher
altertümlicher das ist etwas was man
massiv unterschätzt und ich glaube auch
dass innerhalb der jeweiligen Nation und
auch der Wirtschaften sehr sehr viele
Ideen schlummern wie man das verbessern
kann wie man auf kurzen Wege da auch mit
Biodiesel was ist auch mal sein mag
tatsächlich mehr Fortschritt erreichen
kann ich persönlich halte nichts von
diesen supranationalen Lösungen weil das
führt zu keiner Lösung in den meisten
Fällen wir brauchen dann Entschlackung
dass einfach auf kleiner Ebene auf dem
kurzen Dienstweg was verändert werden
kann so dass sich dann halt Baby
Schenker oder irgend jemand anders zum
alternativen Kraftstoff entscheiden
hilft Ihnen mehr als Unternehmerin ein
Verbot oder ein Gebot ein einfach nur
Freiheit also tatsächlich
Rahmenbedingungen die ein die einen
erlauben vielleicht auch mal mit
Steuervorteilen einfach Investitionen zu
tätigen
und da bin ich sehr sehr nah bei der FDP
dass man sich auch anschaut okay wie
kann man sich tatsächlich jetzt mit
Innovationen auch Welt auf der ganzen
auf der in der Weltpolitik anders
aufstellen das Thema Solar ein ein
Patent und eine Kreation die Deutschland
hervorgerufen hat womit mittlerweile
extrem viel Potenzial weltweit gehoben
wird und wir haben es verpasst davon
ökonomisches partizipieren dass das darf
nicht sein einfach wieder mal eine
Gedanken gewöhnen Politik ist von den
von der Aktualität der Probleme und fand
deren Wucht eigentlich immer überfordert
sie kommt immer zu spät sie handelt
immer erst dann wenn die Probleme
unabweisbar sind und in diesem Fall
Klimaschutz ist es dann unabweisbar wenn
nichts mehr zu retten ist oder nicht
mehr viel zu retten ist vielleicht würde
sich das ändern wenn in den USA
Waffenlager überschwemmt würden oder die
klimademonstrenten würden nicht mehr
friedlich sein sondern Anfang die
Regierungszentralen zu zerkloppen dann
würde sich vielleicht irgendwas ändern
aber ich habe meine Hoffnung setze ich
nur in ja in die Kreativität von
Ingenieuren und Unternehmen muss ich
sagen ich glaube sowieso nicht dran dass
der Staat mit dem irrsinnlichen
Milliardensummen etwas bewegt das ist
üblicherweise die deutsche Debatte haben
wir denn genug Geld um das alles zu
finanzieren man muss nur den
Unternehmern und den den den Ingenieuren
und kreativen die Möglichkeit geben ihre
eigenen Möglichkeiten auszuschöpfen und
das stimme ich mit ihnen völlig überein
die FDP hat vorgeschlagen eine
Sonderabschreibung von zwei Jahren dann
hat man das Investment völlig von der
Steuer wieder reingeholt
Sonderabschreibung auf alles was im
klimaschutzdienst ist viel sinnvoller
als irgendwer ein riesen öffentliches
förderbar